la conférence de presse de la Transat
Jacques Vabre 2023 vient tout juste de
se terminer il y aura deux ivinois au
départ de cette compétition il y aura
notamment ériic Bellon le versaillais
alors ériic tu repars sur cette transat
jacva pour la deuxème fois et ouais la
première fois c'était en 2015 avec Sam
Goodchild qui aussi participe cette
année et là cette année avec Martin le
pape donc je super content et surtout là
cette année j'y vais avec un bateau que
j'ai construit que j'ai coconçu avec
Jean Le Cam et David raison donc la
dernière fois c'était avec un bateau que
j'avais racheté un bateau d'occasion là
c'est avec vraiment mon bateau donc je
suis très très heureux d'être là quoi et
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour toi la
transate javab bah c'est une c'est une
transate qui est assez mythique hein 993
la la première a tous les les grands
champions que que j'ai lu dans ma
jeunesse qui ont participé donc j'ai
l'impression de marcher sur leur trac au
niveau du parcours on part du Havre pour
arriver en Martinique quelles seront les
difficultés peut-être à à éviter pendant
la compétition ah il y en a plusieurs
déjà il y a le départ qui est toujours
un moment sensible on a déjà parlé
ensemble he et il y aura beaucoup de
bateaux he cette année voilà on est on
est quasiment sans bateau même s'il y a
des départs séparés donc ça c'est une
très bonne nouvelle donc les imoka on
est déjà enfin on va être 40 donc déjà
c'est pas mal donc déjà voilà échapper
au départ pas taper d're bateau ensuite
sortir de la Manche la manche c'est
quand même un c'est un gros dossier
parce qu'il y a des courants très très
forts et puis ensuite prendre les
alisées passer l'équateur une fois et
notamment la
zone de convergence intertropiticale
donc c'est endroit où le le vent ne
souffle plus horizontalement mais
verticalement il faudra pas le passer
une fois mais deux fois et puis après
aller vers les les Antilles donc ouais
c'est semé d'embuch tu vises quoi sur
cette compétition tu vises une place
dans le top 10 dans le top 15 qu'est-ce
que tu vises moi je raisonne jamais
comme ça
euh on a un bâtau neuf avec Martin on on
commence à bien se connaître euh moi ce
que je veux c'est qu'à la fin on soit
très fier de nous alors c'est pas un
résultat qui va nous rendre fier si ça
se trouve on va avoir des des tas de
problèmes et on va arriver dans les
derniers mais peut-être qu'on sera très
fier de ça ou alors on aura pas de
problème le bateau va s'exprimer à son
gros potentiel et on va être peut-être
on va peut-être gagner on va peut-être
être devant je sais pas et moi ce que je
veux c'est être fier à la fin c'est
voilà je veux donner mon maximum sur
certaines compétitions tu as prenez la
lenteur si si je peux dire au niveau de
la navigation cette fois-ci tu gommes
tout et tu vises la
vitesse sur la goelette oui j'ai j'ai
participé à la route du Rome en 2018 sur
une goelette classique et c'était pour
voir si je pouvais atteindre justement
la cette satisfaction sans la la vitesse
et l'adrénaline et c'était une grande
découverte et j'ai découvert qu'en fait
dans la vie il faut savoir accélérer et
freiner et souvent on fait que accélérer
et j'étais très content de freiner mais
là c'est sûr que j'y vais pour accélérer
je freinerai plus tard on va parler de
stand as one parle-nous du projet un
stadinwan c'est la continuité de comme
un seul homme qui s'est anglicisé donc
c'est une une action pour promouvoir le
l'aventure collective donc on est
associé à une goélette la fameuse
goélette avec laquelle j'ai j'ai
traversé en 2018 on embarque des jeunes
de la ruralité ou des quartiers
défavorisés pour leur apprendre
justement le à aller vers l'aventure
collective pas dans le recigement sur
soi et puis au niveau sportif c'est
aussi un un projet qu'on a mené avec
Jean Lecam pour faire des bateaux euh
révolutionnairement sobre et tout un
développement mutualisé donc c'est à la
fois de l'aspect sociétal et l'aspect
environnemental et moi j'aime bien à
penser qu'on peut avoir une performance
respectueuse de la nature et de l'homme
c'est c'est ça stazan parlenous de ton
bateau je crois qu'il est nouveau he si
je me trompe pas ouais on l'a mis à l'au
au mois de juin c'est un bateau donc que
j'ai conçu avec Jean Le Cam et David
Raison qui est l'architecte donc c'est
un bateau qui est un bateau à droite
c'est le seul bateau neuf à des rives
droitees de toute la toute la classe
c'est un bateau qu'on a voulu moins cher
moins polant moins émetteur de déchets
aussi donc c'est un bateau qui pour nous
est l'avenir parce que je trouve que
pour ma part l'avenir est à la sobriété
à la simplicité et pas à la complexité
donc voilà c'est une proposition qu'on
fait avec Jean Lecam et et on pense que
ce bateau peut être aussi performant ou
peut-être mieux plus plus performant que
certains bateaux particulièrement sur le
vent des globes qui notre notre objectif
avec ce bateau oui justement j'allais
parler du vent desgobes tu vas partir
avec ce bateau sur le vent desgobes
c'est l'objectif on a dessiné ce
bateau-l avec gens pour le le vend des
globes et donc notre idée c'est d'aller
faire une performance sur le vend des
globes ça sera ton deuxième vend
desgobes qu'est-ce que tu vises pareil
sur cette compétition al moi c'est de me
battre avec les meilleurs et donc tous
ceux qui ont des bateaux neufs à foil
c'est les bateaux qui volent nous je
veux démontrer avec Jean Le Cam que on
peut avoir on peut faire la même
performance ou être encore meilleur en
pensant complètement différents et en
étant plus sobre plus simple moins cher
plus accessible dernière question
qu'est-ce qu'on peut te souhaiter pour
cette Transat Jacques Vabre 2023 Éric
ben amener stanazwan le plus haut
possible et puis être heureux voilà et
faire faire vivre cette course du mieux
possible à nos partenaires qui nous
suivent qu' cette hardiesse de suivre un
projet qui est radicalement différent
des autres voilà et qu'on qu'on soit
heureux tous à la fin de de la belle
performance quelle qu'elle soit en fait
un petit mot pour les Versaillais qui
vont te suivre sur la compétition allez
vive Versailles c'est la plus belle
ville du monde merci à Éric Bellon la
trans Jack Vabre 2023 partira le 29
octobre depuis Le Havre pour rejoindre
la Martinique